So we have three functions
that are graphed here.
We have f of x graphed
in this dotted magenta.
We have g of x in this green.
And then we have h of x
in this dotted purple.
And then we have three
potential equations
that could also be used
to define functions.
And what I want you to
do is think about which
of these equations match up to
which of these function graphs.
So let's go through
them one by one.
So this first one is
reasonably straightforward.
This is just a
straight-up quadratic.
Right over here, y is equal
to 1/2 x squared minus 9/2.
And we see that the coefficient
on the second degree term,
or the highest degree term
right over, here is positive.
It is 1/2.
So this is going to be an
upward-opening parabola.
It's going to look
something like that.
And when we look at all of
these options over here,
there's only one upward
opening parabola.
And that is g of x.
So we know that if this has
got to be one of these three,
this right over here is g of x.
So we could say that g of
x is equal to 1/2 x squared
minus 9/2.
Another giveaway that g of x, or
that g is being described by y
is equal to 1/2 x
squared, minus 9/2,
is you see when x
is equal to 0, we
have our y-intercept
at negative 9/2,
which is the same thing
as negative 4 and 1/2.
And you see that is indeed the
case for g right over there.
It's when x is 0, y
is negative 4 and 1/2.
So we could feel pretty
confident about that.
Now let's look at
these next two.
And what I'm going
to do, let me try
to rewrite them in
a neutral color.
So we don't use blue yet.
So let's think about this one. y
is equal to negative 1/10 times
x plus 3 times x
squared minus 9.
Now, we could take the
trouble of multiplying
all of this stuff out.
Or we could just think about
what is the highest-degree term
going to look like?
And we could also think about
what does the lowest degree
term look like?
What is the constant term?
So the highest-degree term is
going to be negative 1/10 times
x times x squared.
So this is going to be y
is equal to negative 1/10
x to the third power.
Then you're going to have a
bunch of other terms in there.
And then you're going to
have your lowest-- maybe I'll
write a plus although
it might be a minus,
but then you're going have a
bunch of other terms there.
And then you're going to have
your lowest-degree term, which
is going to be negative 9
times 3, which is negative 27,
times negative 1/10.
Well, that's just
going to be positive
27/10, which is the
same thing as 2.7.
Now, just from
this, without even
knowing all of this
business in the middle,
we can start to think about
what this graph is actually
going to look like.
First of all, we see it is
a third-degree polynomial,
or it's a third-degree
expression,
I guess we could say.
And its coefficient on the
third-degree term is negative.
So that means it's going to have
end behavior like negative x
to the third.
x to the third looks like this.
Negative x to the third will
look something like this.
So its end behavior is
going to look like that.
We could think about what
it does in the middle.
It might jump up and
do something like that.
But that's what it's end
behavior is going to be.
It has end behavior like
negative x to the third.
Now, which of these graphs
have that type of end behavior?
Well, it's pretty clear that h
of x, when x is very negative,
h of x is positive,
just like this.
When x is very positive,
h of x is very negative.
It is the only of these three
graphs that have that behavior.
So we can feel pretty
confident that this is h of x.
Now, if we're not
sure, we could also
look at the y-intercept
right over here.
When x is equal to 0, all
these other terms are 0.
And so y is going to be 2.7.
And we see that is indeed
the case right over here.
When x is 0, y is 2.7.
So that gives us some
confidence as well.
Now, let's look at
this third expression.
And obviously we
could just deduce
that there's only one equation
left and one function left.
So this has got to be f of x.
But let's say we
didn't know that.
Let's see how we
could reason it out.
So once again, let's think
about multiplying-- figure
out what the highest
degree term is.
Well, the highest-degree
term is going
to be 1/10 times x
squared times x squared.
So we can rewrite this
one as 1/10-- x squared
times x squared is x
to the fourth power.
Then we're going to
have a bunch of terms.
And then our lowest-degree term
is going to be 9 times 9 times
1/10.
That's 81 divided by 10.
So that is 8.1.
So what type of end to
behavior is this going to have?
You have an even-degree
polynomial right over here,
and it has a
positive coefficient.
So it's going to
have end behavior
like a second-degree polynomial
with a positive coefficient.
Or it's going to have end
behavior like x squared.
So it's going to look--
when x is a really negative,
it's going to be
really positive.
And then when x is
really positive,
it's going to be
really positive.
So it's end behavior is
going to look like that,
and it might do some
business in between.
Well, which of these
graphs do that?
Well, it's pretty
clear that f definitely
has that type of end behavior.
It does something a little
interesting in the middle.
And if we wanted to
be sure, we could
look at this intercept
right over here.
When x is 0, all these other
terms are going to be 0,
and you're going to be left just
with this y-intercept, which
is 8.1.
And so when x is 0
we do see, indeed,
that f is sitting here at 8.1.
So we can feel pretty confident
that that right over there
is f of x.